Bud Light is uh getting a lot of heat
right now I don't know if you've heard
this they did a pact with a they did a
collaboration with a trans activist okay
Dylan Mulvaney
um and a lot of I think people were
wondering if this was fake or real it is
real
um and Bud Light said that helps
authentically connect with audiences and
uh scroll down
this is the collaboration can is it real
it is real
I just don't understand that I don't
understand that as a marketing tool
unless maybe
they know something that we don't
maybe they're trying to like you start
to think if there's bigger powers out
there that are influencing like they
want more confrontative type stuff
you know I just don't understand the
connection like unless you want
I don't know if Bud Light drink I just
don't know if I'm a Bud Light if I'm a
beer if I want to get something that's
making me discuss like a topic that's
argumentative
yeah I would adventure to say most of
their clients aren't interested in that
right that's what they yeah it's like
it's almost that like thing where it's
like why
do you put it if it's something just let
it be something why does it have to be
something that you use as a uh tool for
marketing all the time
I think they're just trying to get in
the trans Market you think so
how much how many trans people are there
um okay this is a UCLA study
from June 2022
nearly one in five people who identified
as transgender are ages 13 to 17.
hmm
1.6 million people ages 13 and up
identify as trans that's this number is
right here
what percent of humans
are trans
folks
you know the idea 1.6 million people
ages 13 and up identify as transgender
and and I guess and that's what does it
mean identify you know do you think
trans people drink Bud Light
oh I bet I bet after you go home and you
take off the lashes and then it's like
oh Ron
what a [__] day over there outside of
Claire's Boutique you know what a day
the uh Courthouse my God
these heels are killing me huh let me
put my Crocs back on and light up a
Marlboro Red I think yeah I think for
sure dude after you go home look after
every man goes home from work and takes
off the whatever the job is I don't care
if the job is lipstick
um or wait without you know if you do
whatever you do if you do hair extension
whatever uh yeah you [__] definitely
want a cold one
so maybe they're onto something
maybe they're on to something I just
wondered does Nate what does nature do
because I wonder sometimes
what is going on or more people just
identifying
that they don't know how they feel
genetically or more people saying I want
another wiener or no
uh
uh vagina
what are they saying
yeah they probably just want to lose the
given one and get a different one damn
and what do they do they fill the vagina
in with what wiener
uh
you know something along those lines
probably or close to it I think it's a
little bit I think they're getting
better at it each year wow man we gotta
have a we should have a surgeon on to
discuss that
um okay what else yeah I guess what do
you think do you think Bud Light
drinkers are gonna
I wonder if they I wonder if people who
used to identify as men drank Bud Light
and then transition to women and stop
drinking Bud Light because it doesn't
fit that Vibe and now bud light's like
well
you like it
you know you can drink maybe they're
trying to normalize drinking it for
for Trans people but it's really you're
going for a very small Market
1.7 million
right but what's the other size of the
world I guess those are 13 and up we
don't know how many of them can drink
yeah so
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one